no I shot him
bullets in the fall kill him
collateral is directed by Michael Mann
I'm currently Vincent Tom Cruise from
collateral big thanks to the wife for
helping me out with this costume I loved
it but if you really want to take me
seriously during this review I probably
shouldn't look like this the entire time
but I thought it'd be so much fun to
dress up like him just for a little bit
that being said let's get started with
collateral ah the wonders of temporary
hair dye was a lot of fun thanks for
watching that guys don't worry I'm not
gonna wear these throughout the entire
review but the suit is gonna stay
collateral is one of my all-time
favorite movies and if you guys are
newer or haven't really seen where these
reviews for awhile from time to time I
do have a segment entitled in my
favorite movies in which I talk about my
favorite movies I'll never forget the
first time I saw it unfortunately it was
at home I didn't get a chance to see
this one in theaters because I'm stupid
I didn't go for some dumb reason I don't
even remember what I was doing back then
but I did see it at home and I remember
this warm feeling overtaking my body
this feeling of suspense in tension and
I was so awestruck by Michael Mann's
brilliant vision of la nightlife because
at that time I hadn't yet seen heat and
I love me some heat but to this day
collateral is my all-time favorite
Michael Mann movie this movie has such a
great plot for a few different reasons
that I'm about to get into Tom Cruise
plays Vincent he's a hit man who gets in
the cab driven by Jamie Foxx who has
dreams of starting his own limo company
and he forces max played by Jamie Foxx
to drive him to his various hits
throughout one really shitty night for
max now as I said this plot works really
well for a lot of different reasons for
one Tom Cruise gets to play a villain
how rare is that and how awesome is that
you could argue that maybe Tropic
Thunder is one of the only other times
this guy's played a true villain
maybe interview with a vampire for the
most part Tom Cruise is always the cool
hero guy it was so cool to see him
completely unplugged from all of that
also it's two different types of plots
you have a very contained movie in a cab
the dialogue between these two men gets
very philosophical at times they explore
one another's lives their past lives you
learn so much about them
Michael Mann even gave Tom Cruise a
folder depicting photographs and
locations of his childhood growing up so
the cruise could learn more about his
character and that's just how brilliant
Michael Mann works but you have what
might be considered a contained thriller
within this cab very claustrophobic but
the other side of it is that when they
get out into LA and the nightclub scenes
and back alleyways abandoned streets in
the middle of the night at 4:00 in the
morning it becomes this incredible open
thriller in the city of La so you have
two amazing thrillers bouncing back and
forth with one another you could look at
this movie and say collateral as an
action movie and you'd be right but
really it's a drama about these two
characters they're polar opposites and
then the things about them that are
strikingly similar and I'm not going to
get into spoilers with this review just
in case you haven't seen it because I
think this movie is one of the best
action thrillers ever made now let's
talk about why is it because of the way
the actions filmed well sure the
handheld scene in the nightclub is
astoundingly brilliant it's one of the
best action scenes ever put to screen
for one the soundtrack introduced me to
Tom Rothrock it introduced me to the
roots before I ever heard the man Jimmy
Fallon and I could talk about the
cinematography in this movie for the
rest of my life it is the coolest I have
ever seen LA at night and I've been to
LA many times at night and it's never
ever looked as good as it does in
collateral Mann utilized a lot of
low-budget HD cameras for this movie and
it gives the movie this grainy crispness
that I've never seen another film half
this performance by Tom Cruise is
competing with just a few others as my
favorite of his he's ever done of course
he brings a lot to the physical scenes
but he brings even more to these scenes
in the cab with Jamie Foxx's character
where he's talking about his past life
with his father or the fact that he
doesn't really have any plans for the
future he's just strolling through this
strange life as a hitman just going from
job to job and you start to imagine what
does this guy do in his downtime what is
he doing when he's not on a job what is
actually going on with this guy he's a
little crazy and Jamie Foxx gives in my
opinion still his best performance you
can argue about ray forever ray is a
great performance but he is imitating
someone who already existed
this is a wholly original performance I
still think it's Jamie Foxx's best and
he was nominated for Best Supporting
Actor and his interplay with Cruz is
just fantastic and one of the things
that's so good about it is you explore
Max's character he talks about wanting
to start his own limo company Island
limos cool groove experience when you
get to the airport you're not going to
want to get out of my limo but as
Vincent continues to ask him about this
you learn that he's been a cab driver
for way way too long and so you start to
learn more about his character and you
realize this is also kind of a broken
man and in the strangest way these two
guys who should hate one another
have a sort of brotherly connection that
starts to flow throughout the movie and
it's so well realized in the script in
the direction and the performances
there's not another movie
like Collateral in existence just the
feel of it all from the jazzy music the
suspense created wondering when Tom
Cruise's character is just gonna snap
and shoot somebody and of course I have
to mention your homey
is that my briefcase yeah why you want
it back
if you haven't seen collateral just wait
for that scene it's incredible it's so
great also extremely underrated in this
movie is Mark Ruffalo this is the first
time I ever paid notice to this actor
and he certainly hasn't disappointed me
since he continues to be an incredibly
underrated actor to this day he plays a
cop who's on the trail of this situation
and he might just be the only person who
believes Max's story about what's going
on and because of that you really start
to get into this guy's of life and you
wonder what does he do on his downtime
as well all of these characters are so
well fleshed out that you actually begin
to think like what are these guys doing
when they're not in this movie and
you're like wait this is just actors
holy like this is excellent writing
now the credited writer on this
screenplay is stuart beattie who later
wrote and directed i Frankenstein there
was a rumor for a long time that Frank
Darabont and Michael Mann both did an
uncredited rewrite of the script after
seeing i Frankenstein I'm inclined to
believe that rumor is true so whoever
wrote it it's freaking great I can
actually give this movie my highest
compliment that I can possibly give a
movie this movie inspired me to want to
make movies it was one of the movies
I saw back in the day that made me want
to make a movie that took place in the
city at night it made me inspired to go
out in my city nearby my house and
actually make a film that's the highest
praise I can give a movie this movie
reminded me why I want to make movies
and whenever I'm not feeling inspired I
can turn on collateral and feel a rush
of creativity if you guys haven't seen
it I strongly suggested it is one of my
all-time favorite movies and collateral
absolutely gets an A+ guys I really
appreciate you watching this and I also
want to let you know a lot of people
have asked me one specific question
where do you get all your t-shirts you
know where do you get all your posters
where do you get all of this there's a
lot of different places but there is one
specific website that I do a lot of my
t-shirts from I'm not wearing one of
those t-shirts now but that is jack
threads.com however they did actually
furnish me with this suit they were kind
enough to give me this suit for my
collateral review which was incredible
of them and I have to give a humongous
thank you to jack threads.com for doing
that because this was like awesome I was
like I really want to do a collateral
review and they actually let me get a
suit that resembles Tom Cruise's in
collateral so because of how awesome
they were because you guys are always
asking me where I get my t-shirts and
things like that if you go to jack
threads.com slash chris and use the
promo code chris you can get 15% off
anything my gift to you guys through
Jackthreads
they were so so awesome to send me this
suit I also have a couple other t-shirts
I'm going to be wearing and some other
reviews soon maybe something with Bob
Ross the painter on it
I just love Bob Ross just a happy little
treat right there oh yes make love to
the tree Oh
draw the tree make love to the tree it's
so amazing so if you guys do go to jack
threads.com slash Chris and use the
promo code Chris when you check out for
anything you get in the store you can
get 15% off thank you so much to them
for the suit I really appreciate it and
I hope they liked the review and I hope
you guys dug the review as well as my
incredibly awesome gray hair and beard
that I had earlier so guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes